hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm here with Rosanna pansino or
grow as I was instructed to call her and
we're gonna be playing the urban
dictionary challenge and what that means
is our friends behind the camera there's
a whole bunch of them they all picked
out some words from the urban dictionary
and we're gonna try to guess what they
mean I know a lot about the Internet she
does not not at all
no she didn't even know what Netflix and
chill meant it was an accident it was an
accident
so what we're gonna be doing is we're
gonna be playing this we're gonna
discuss we're gonna write down our
answers and then we're gonna show you
guys there's nothing there don't worry
it's not we're gonna be playing the game
I have nothing else to say we're gonna
get started
these are scented so so we're gonna be
playing ready go is what like wardrobe
and chair chair drove I know what it
means I think I know I know what it may
be yeah I know what it means
I know are you ready yeah of course
three two one it's the chair you throw
your clothes on when you're too lazy to
put them away that's kind of what I said
I said after a long day you throw your
clothes on the chair exactly that is a
point for each of us ding ding your
second word word word is ghost cheese
ghost what I don't know if I know what
this means
I don't either but I'm making my best
guess okay I got it okay three two one
BAM the cheeks of a meth addict just an
empty end but untanned but was that me
oh oh wait behind the
tastes good FLI we gotta come up with
what this acronym means okay the GE part
doesn't make sense I've gotten
everything up to that part I'm not gonna
look oh I know I know what it is but I
don't know what this is I got it on lock
I am a hundred percent right three two
one BAM I love you so much that I feel
like I'm gonna explode that's gonna be
it
I had that's gotta be it word for word
word for word
no all right quarter point but I don't
even know how we're gonna score with
quarter points office quarterback okay
I've got my answer not ready probably
not right I'm ready
three two one it's the the guy in the
office that always wants the smallest
amount of change back so even if you
lend him a quarter
ah the quarterback I get it that is
really good I said someone who throws
all their work to other people oh that
makes sense is that what it is
oh I shouldn't be giving her that corner
boy your next word in Jotunheimen
kitchen what kitchen heimer kitchen
higher huh I know this kitchen heimer
ready he's confident yes okay three two
one mine's a sous chef to a kitchen
Hitler coz wasn't wasn't
himer Oppenheimer or something like that
was one of Hitler's henchmen and
therefore a kitchen himer
would be the subordinate of a kitchen
Hitler so he aids in his crusade against
everyone in his kitchen right that's
pretty detailed all I've got is when you
get high in your kitchen while you're
baking something with the timer on and
then you know when it's done
when you're and then you just guess you
guess when it's done that's the kitchen
when you're high Murr you just guess
when it's done I like the mind better
can someone add an urban dictionary
entry body booking body booking body
booking
ready me too 3 2 1
I said a hooker that's really good at
scheduling appointments she's a good
body Booker he's a good body Booker
hooker Yeah right I thought I bet
instead of like body building but
building your mind by reading lots of
books so your mind is getting stronger
like that's really clever
I was thinking body building body yeah
pretty dare you she can raid
I liked ours better all all of these
need to be added to urban dictionary
after we're done what slacker Bagon
slacker bagging three two one okay
slacker bagging [ __ ] slacker bagging
when you're too poor to afford more than
one sleeping bag and you have to share
with all your bros like on a camping
trip there's three you only got one bag
so you got to snuggle up it's functional
for both warmth and comfort and safety I
like just want to give you a point cuz
that was such a good answer I be
fiddling I go into that I made it sexy I
said hooking up with slackers without a
depth I do that well that's just eating
chips it's calling me food just eating
chips cuz I don't want to have a dip
with my chip
your next word is trying to guess how
urban dictionary would describe the word
NASCAR three two one all right a NASCAR
is a car where three of the four
passengers are actually trash that car
that's on NASCAR in a nasty car get it
it sounds worse when I say it out loud
but it's a NASCAR I get it I just
actually tried to define NASCAR I'm
moving it Urban Dictionary is just gonna
give this one to NASCAR racing my other
definition is very simple it's a car
whose steering is broken and it can only
turn left what is it it is going in the
loop oh I get it
no I'm not counting it as a point no
points no she got like half a point a
quarter yes
got a quarter point okay okay ready
three two all right eating the good food
first before anyone else can get to it
yeah I I also said eating quickly so
others don't take your food
yeah well ideally you only get the good
food that's right right well no that's
correct I think they're both equally
right yeah ding ding ding please please
please this next one could determine
everything yeah that means this is under
the wire last question all comes down to
this this is a tight game your final
word oh is backseat browser taxi browser
Oh oh yeah my sister does this to me all
the time three-two-one it's someone
who's watching you browse the web from
behind you control what you do mmm-hmm I
said when you're on the computer
searching for something and another
person is trying to tell you how to
search for it better yeah Molly Molly
all right you both get a point which
means Row one mark you do not know how
rare this is
I hardly ever win challenges thank you
everybody so much for watching thank you
ro for having me in your lovely house on
this lovely challenge video and if you
haven't seen it yet in the description
there'll be a link over to the nerdy
nummies episode where we make something
cool related to something I do probably
too much on my channel so check it out
thank you everybody again for watching
and as always I'll see you in the next
video bye bye